hi morning thank you for joining us on
the early rundown so leading the news
this Monday morning the UK's first red
extreme heat warning has come into force
with temperatures predicted to hit 40
degrees celsius today or tomorrow and
break the records for the UK's hottest
ever day look at that the scene across
West London right now the sun rose at
four minutes past five so around an hour
ago and that temperature is going to
steadily creep up during the day until
it becomes dangerous a level four heat
Health Emergency has been declared
meaning even fit and healthy people are
in danger from this extreme heat
an Amber warning already covers much of
England all of Wales and Southern
Scotland a red warning for extreme heat
is now in force and that covers an area
starting south of London in stretches as
far north as greater Manchester and York
some trains have been canceled as
temperatures soar with network rails
saying in serious cases railway tracks
could Buckle in the extreme heat and
therefore speed restrictions would be in
place the department for education is
not telling schools to close but some
schools would actually allow children to
leave early or wear PE kit so they feel
more comfortable while the government is
advising people to work from home where
possible our top story on our main
report today from Ashley
we've had the warnings and now it's here
today this familiar sight will feel
unfamiliar
over the next few hours extreme heat
will smolder towns and cities between
London and York
many of those winding down after the
weekend are today staying home
but I'm choosing to stay at home because
I don't want to get public transport
because it's great going to work
aircon's on but then you've still got to
get home but the office has been closed
to prevent people from traveling in in
light of the likely travel disruption so
I'm forced to work from home I've worked
abroad in hot countries part of my job
so 40 degrees 45 degrees when I've been
working abroad you just get on with it
but those in classrooms have little
choice
in some of the schools it means closing
some of the rooms in some of the schools
it might mean closing early today it
means all of us making sure that
children have enough water have
protection against the sun are wearing
hats are wearing loose clothing we can't
expect much learning to go on in this
sort of heat there's the the Frank
reality
taking it easy is precisely what the NHS
wants us to do hospitals will be pushed
over the next 48 hours some one-on-one
control rooms have drafted in extra
staff an urge to only call in an
emergency even then it's expect a long
wait
today of all days is not the day to go
outside Network Rel have said that
people should only travel if it's
absolutely necessary and for vulnerable
people to not travel at all
By Night the risks for them continue
people will dehydrate and the strain of
people's breathing is much higher again
people who have breathing difficulties
are much better sat up and so the
overnight heat will give people a little
respite people get a very little sleep
in many cases
this is what the water networks will
want to avoid bottles being handed out
to those finding themselves without in
the middle of the most severe heat wave
the country has ever seen
what happens in the skies today may look
appealing but in reality it's extremely
dangerous ashnaharanag Sky News
now throughout the course of the morning
we're going to show you this live image
from West London just seeing how things
are going to change during the course of
the morning and in in fact the day
Sunrise to remind you was just an hour
ago the temperature in London for many
comfortable right now but it is just
after six in the morning by late
afternoon when the sun has moved from
the East towards the West the heat is
likely to be at its highest and that's
when the record for the UK's highest
temperature could be broken let me just
remind you that highest temperature is
38.7 Celsius Celsius it was set in the
botanic gardens in Cambridge back in
2019 but all signs that it could be
surpassed 40 degrees is potentially
predicted today or tomorrow uh well
let's get the latest from our
correspondent shingi malarico who is in
reading for us this morning good to see
you shingy how are things looking there
morning Nick so the sun hasn't quite set
in and it's not baking yet here and
people are here for their early morning
swim at this slider and like you said
large parts of the country are now
waking up to the first ever red weather
warning for extreme Heats with
temperatures expected to reach record
levels and with that ferocious heat as
it's being described will come travel
disruption and another important note
about that met office warning the first
time it's ever been introduced is that
the health issues related to the heat
won't just impact people who are
vulnerable but people of all ages
profiles and backgrounds and like I say
that will come with sweeping disruption
the rail networks are telling people to
avoid travel unless it is completely
necessary the RAC of telling people to
keep off the roads at the moment when
the sun is at its hottest and here
people are coming for a swim but it's
also been noted over the last couple of
days that there have been a number of
incidents of people getting into
difficulty while some in Open Water this
is natural to scenario but at this slide
though they've had to change their
services so they're booked out all day
for swimming but they also offer spa and
massage treatments and they were saying
that those have had to be rejiggled had
to be moved around because it's simply
too hot for someone to have a spa day in
these conditions and a large part of
that met warning is that this isn't a
day for leisure and enjoyment it's a day
of extreme temperatures linked to
climate change the sorter temperatures
that could have an impact on people's
Lifestyles and the country's
infrastructure as well
yeah I know they say it's a lovely hot
day it's not one of those that you can
put on sunscreen go out and enjoy a swim
and a meal outside the message of course
to stay safe thanks a lot to Changi for
now
well let's take a look at what is in
store and it looks like the current
record as I was saying in the UK 38.7
Celsius will almost definitely be broken
today or tomorrow temperatures today is
set to hit 39 degrees could get up to 40
Celsius tomorrow so the heat will be
intense but it actually won't last as
you can see there temperatures expected
to drop dramatically from Wednesday
onwards returning to more normal levels
something that much more comfortable I
guess for this time of year
now to help you through the hot days and
what are going to be incredibly warm
nights we have collated some of the top
tips to stay cool first up how do you
get through the day well it's important
to cool yourself from the inside by
drinking plenty of fluids but avoid
alcohol and caffeine it might seem
counter-intuitive but stay inside keep
your windows closed and curtains drawn
to keep this intense heat out if you're
worried about heat stroke then soak your
hands and feet in cold water or apply an
ice pack to your armpits and do make
sure to check in on your friends
neighbors and elderly relatives and keep
your pets in the shades
so how do we get through the night well
one tip prepare ahead and stick your
pajamas and pillowcases in the freezer
during the day you might have heard that
then take them out just before you go to
bed you duvet use cotton sheets instead
ideally one per person they will absorb
sweat and a more comfortable in the Heat
and if your home has several floors then
sleep downstairs use a fan if you've got
one to help your body regulate its
internal temperature sticking a pan of
ice cubes in front of it can make the
circulation of air even cooler and if
you have phone chargers next to your bed
unplug them that's wise advice so they
don't heat up your devices and the air
around them
now there are countries where the
temperature regularly hits 40 degrees
we're unused to it here but if you've
lived in Dubai or Las Vegas for example
the chances are that your home and
workplace would be air conditioned but
here we do not build for such extreme
heat climate change means though that we
might have to and that's going to cost
billions to adapt our science
correspondent Thomas More reports
the temperatures Rising with the Sun the
next two days are expected to be the
UK's hottest since records began and
we're just not used to it hundreds of
people are likely to die
not just the temperature it's the
definitely the duration and the fact
that you don't get any respite overnight
uh so you also end up with people
becoming sleep deprived and there's a
cumulative dehydration which compounds
the problems
previous heat waves have underlined the
economic impact too in 2010 5 million
staff days were lost to high
temperatures at a cost of 770 million
pounds
in the 2003 Heatwave Road repairs cost
41 million and in the same year buckling
of rail tracks cost two and a half
million in delays and damage other
countries more used to these
temperatures have invested in more
resilient infrastructure they've
designed their cities to have plenty of
shade and of course they got far more
air conditioning Britain just isn't
built to be this hot
only half of England's strategic Road
network is surfaced with heat resistant
material
and new houses are still so poorly
designed that they'll overheat in future
well Britain just isn't built for the
climate we now have the higher
temperatures we are experiencing over
the next few days and we will find that
our infrastructure our buildings our
roads our rails simply can't cope with
the eaves largely and in the future
we're just going to have to retrofit
them which will be expensive but there
is no choice these heat waves are going
to become more intense and more frequent
greenhouse gas emissions of the past
mean summer temperatures that top 40
degrees are already baked into our
future but how often that happens
depends on weather and how quickly we
reach Net Zero delaying climate action
will simply dial up the heat Thomas More
Sky News
here's a picture we're going to be
showing you throughout the course of the
morning scene from West London the sun
has risen it Rose at four minutes past
five this morning so what's that around
an hour and 10 minutes ago but warnings
to stay safe over the next couple of
days let me tell you that this is being
described as ferocious Heats by the
College of paramedics chief executive
Tracy Nichols you might have seen her on
Sophie Ridge yesterday she said this
isn't like a lovely hot day where we can
put a bit of sunscreen on go out enjoy a
swim and a meal outside this is serious
heat that could actually ultimately end
in people's deaths because it is so
ferocious we know we're not to set up
for this sort of heat in this country
the UK's first red extreme heat warning
is in place that covers a large part of
England ideally from the south of London
to Manchester and York that's in place
until tomorrow there is a heat health
warning issued by the UK Health Security
Agency that's set at level four
described as a National Emergency server
people being told to stay safe Railway
is going to be affected trains canceled
in fact many uh routes they've already
canceled trains that others saying do
not travel rails likely to buckle or
cause
restrictions on speed restrictions on
the tracks to it's going to be hotter
than these Sahara if temperatures get up
to 40 degrees the sun's saying hotter
than the desert there plus India
Pakistan Algeria and Ethiopia the
guardian talking about a ferocious heat
wave as we were saying there to set
temperatures Beyond 40 degrees and The
Mirror Has the headline below torch at
Britain these conditions set to last the
next two days and we said as I say to
break the record beat the record 38.7
Celsius set in Cambridge in 20 2019.